hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to emerge
nyc that's emergency
or emerge nyc
or emergenic
uh it's a fictional they want you to
know that
fictional version of manhattan where you
are a firefighter
now i've played firefighter simulator
this is not that this is a
full recreation of a living breathing
city
fictionally some fire trucks are
equipped with real q sirens
and can be used by pressing q real q
real
real cue real cute sirens oh
my god loading emergency stop
don't do it oh my god
what green dot oh god this city's loud
okay unit what
huh what huh well i still honking me you
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
look at that oh god that's pretty cool
you know just from a city perspective
thing this is pretty neat um
but i have no idea what i'm doing so
you know if i could get some help about
that that'd be great i'm gonna go
back to the main menu there was a
tutorial that i should definitely oh
10 parts 10 parts introduction
oh it's not gameplay oh no
oh no okay guys i'll be right back by
default no playable units vehicles or
characters spawn on the map that's for
performance reasons
players need to spawn in the specific
units that they need in order to spot a
character you must spawn a vehicle first
okay f2 okay parking brake
very important tiller what's a tiller oh
my god
oh my god oh my god full documentation
where do i go for that it's our website
okay that's helpful a little cheat sheet
of things to do
oh my god they aren't joking
with this this is a 56-page manual
holy crap this is taking simulator to
another level
guys hold horse this is
gonna be a bumpy ride i don't know what
i'm doing
but i've got a 56 page manual that is
going to help apparently
oh press question at the top ui tutorial
oh
oh that's okay well that actually that
is helpful because that that does help
um so it's f2 i believe
left alt cursor unlock what what what
no f2 f2 f1
oh my god f2 f3
you said f2 it says f2 spawn unit f2
what what
who's got a rickety ass whatever that is
who's pushing a shopping cart all right
whatever okay
units oh maybe it's already here new
unit oh okay
fire department okay confirm
no fire department engine code 30
okay spawn all
oh oh what wait
spawn all wait all all it's lagging
oh my god oh my god
oh no what have i done
okay chief join i'm going fourth
division
odor none what was the why
odor oh
god morgan
i've got 13 fps go look at the chunking
on his shoulders the weight of the world
on those shoulders and they wouldn't
buckle for a second
oh my god look at this dude
[Laughter]
all right chief morgan my god
look at that beefcake this
man god that swoopy where are you going
i am not moving he's too powerful to be
contained
is it where are you going buddy
where are you going where are you going
man my dude my guy
please
i don't know where he goes
is this like the world's slowest scene
transition
my odor is none so that's good
oh no buddy
okay all right um can i just all right
good i'm just gonna hop in my little
truck here
i think do i just
eye ignition okay parking brake
go baby go where am i oh my god
oh oh that's the door
how do i get out of this neighbor let me
uh
oh yeah that's not the way up let me up
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh sorry i had to bail um
i think i broke it so i'm not gonna do
that
training grounds training grounds
training grounds
training grounds let me get my manual
back up okay training grounds is good
uh-oh it's fine
we recovered that never happens
wow private dwelling multi-tax taxpayer
taxpayer as opposed to what victorian
dwelling where they don't pay taxes yeah
that makes sense
let's save the taxpayer right i get i
get
hey taxpayer
unit new unit fire well this is a much
more logical
thing okay driver officer
let me go driver okay oh my
oh my where did i go what
happened join okay i'm very bouncy
williams okay how's the chunk not as
chunky i gotta admit not as chunk okay
whatever i'm gonna
just oh i see a fire
fire ignition
okay automatic whale
yelp pneumatic horn
why
let's just turn on this yeah oh my god
okay i love it
i don't know why my camera's so low but
oh where is
[Music]
[Applause]
hey i'm actually in this truck this time
oh god no what have i done oh i'm fine
parking brake ignition no keep that on
we need to run the pumps or something
all right i'm hopping out
so i have a phone call apparently
ding-dong
can i get out okay there there okay hey
it's got my name on this that's
good you love to see that all right mr
fire prepare to meet your
maker from mr
william oh okay inlet connection
hydrant discharge connection okay where
okay there's a hydrant i remember okay
we need
relay line relay line
relay line relay
f relay line
relay line
relay line and let me check the guide
real quick
okay uh oh okay i can put on my helmet
well i'm sorry i didn't mean to take my
helmet off i'm sorry
oh my god why why why are you doing that
jay what
stop stop what do you what do you do
stop yeah yeah that's what i thought
okay okay i've got it uh connect the
slot plot
through the slop i need a hydrant wrench
pump menu hydr
wrench hydra bidet is that a bidet for
my butt
is that a butt bidet see open close okay
is there a wrench in there anyone see a
wrench
wrench c wrench
take take it take it do it
take it you want it take it why is there
a bend over button
this actually it's not bend over it's a
slight polite bow actually
oh thank you wrench i appreciate you
thank you maybe like first person this
for a little bit
i see uh okay maybe it's not that
open okay open
interesting all right
open f what ah
maybe not that maybe not that okay e
hose connection
t grab return supply line all
impossible tasks use hydrant wrench
what do you mean what do you mean
hydrant wrench
nice jump man about you
oh great hydrant please give me your
fluids
give me your fluids well this is uh
going real good this place uh
real sturdy real not quite so burnable
which is lucky for me
i can't get anything there so that's
fine what about these other
no other operations oh
with the front okay that that picture is
about the front of the boat
okay what's at the front e ho's
connection well i don't have
i can't either who's got that shopping
cart why is there a shopping cart here
what happened to that bus why is there a
ladder there
i'm going on that ladder look mark
williams is coming along over this
ladder here okay
goof man this fire really chugs my
system
ah can i get a little bit of a
something or other you know
i don't know oh like a wrench
in the wrenches or wrench g take i
ah g take item okay maybe that's what
i'm doing wrong
that looks like a wrench g g it up x
drop item
use item holster item couple item nope
g g g gg
maybe i'm not the right role maybe i got
to be different
control nozzle let me be nozzle man yeah
this looks like a thing hose connection
pull relay line do i have a wrench
hello this is not the right job not the
right
job uniform
oh yeah casual casual
shorts good for fire putting out um well
this [ __ ] is just gonna burn
uh let me look up like vehicle controls
nope no uh character controls okay
control radial men radial radial menu
radial menu okay radial oh
oh e ah oh what is this i
what is that what is it am i detecting
fire
there's fire over there yeah equip equip
what equip what
oh oh
oh oh oh oh oh oh
oh
[Music]
animations smoke cigarette and uh just
gonna let this puppy burn um
don't mind how i smoke my cigarettes
sideways but uh
yeah just uh no casual
what am i doing you're casual you know
shorts are casual
fire's casual
i really see nothing wrong with anything
that's going on here oh my god
oh my god oh my god
no odor on me though odor ain't no
problem
am i still the wrong character of like
control maybe control control could
i like it starting out with shorts your
face is your arms are
you're fine let's do first person okay
pull relay line okay that clearly ain't
happening
so we need to
we need to what is this
it's a grenade launcher hose pack
okay out of first person for the moment
host pack
okay oh
oh i opened it put it put it in the
put it in the thing put it in the thing
do the thing
oh please you're so close
what e e okay
put it away because we're about to get
the
hose put
what holds hose hose
relay line stretch six
lengths please five four three two
i one any any length any length
what so i'm close to the answer
i'm close i'm getting real close here
okay
maybe maybe i'm not close enough
to the fire hydrant start parking brake
alarm hello start
start it up this is cause i'm not a
driver am i not in the right spot
no hello
hello
i'm gonna figure this out and i'm gonna
be right back okay all right cool thanks
bye
so i solved the problem and i solved it
by giving up
and that just goes to show that you can
solve all your problems by giving up
just remember markiplier tells you to
give up
so what i'm gonna what i'm gonna do is
uh there's also a different thing
so why
what okay there's also um more different
thing to do uh like say for example
ambulance so ambi
emerald
i'm not anything with the mouse
what okay i i
firmly believe i firmly believe
that this is my fault and not the game i
believe that the game is
in depth and has a lot of complexity
that i need
that i need to just accept and i am bad
and it is not
so with that in mind
trailer park what
i don't know where that is oh god i
didn't mean
fire where was yours if why why fire
oh oh god i can't turn it off because
fire once started go
oh god god i'm sorry i'm not that kind
of truck
well subway what a subway fire
is this is all fire multiple dwelling
light it all
up light everything up why not i wanted
to do
a emt stuff
but no ms01
join join
join loading
okay i think that's enough tutorial for
me i've really got a grasp of the game
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go back into the real city and i'm going
to give this a real go
and i'm going to save lives and property
in that order because lives are more
important
okay we're going fire department
i'm gonna spawn engine co 30 so it's
there
cancel that go here go to driver
okay i'm now the driver yeah mark brady
okay so i'm getting in the truck
i am in the truck startup truck
parking brake off
how do i open garage how do i open the
garage
is there a garage opener hats t-shirts
pet what
uh let me just oh
wow hey hold on it's gonna be like a
here we go okay oh
made mayday alert uh i'm just gonna
generate a new call
okay incident nothing it's it's nothing
what
odor of gas multiple dwelling odor okay
open the door
open the door how do you open the door
how do you open the garage door
how do you open the garage
door the garage
okay open bay
oh you right click
that's it okay we're on the way
get out of the way move
we got an emergency drift
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you doing get away
[Music]
now
[Applause]
oh my god yeah there you go one
okay went into oblivion but that's fair
at least they're out of the way okay
where is it where is
it it's here somewhere where is it
anybody see it
huh where'd it go oh what the heck
i don't i don't see it
i'm not seeing it excuse me ma'am hello
hello hello uh hello
this don't look like a fire
hello was it unlock open close
okay high
slight odor of gas well okay
locked it was a way to open
locked doors i think hang on okay
there's a menu okay
right the menu can i get the min there
we go
okay shut down gas
kick door
hello well my job is done
i
let's make an ems you know there's an
ems yeah
yes
coroner oh a coroner van oh
i'm the i'm a coroner i
ain't my guy ain't dead i can't even get
in my car i can't
get in my car how do i get in my car car
stretcher stretch stretcher
car hello
oh hi are you okay you need to help
i can't even get in my car see uh dredge
ambulance that sounds good
oh yeah that looks standard okay
i'm about that paramedic yeah
okay cool yeah all right
yo get in no
can't there no no the answer is no one
of these is gonna work
ems supervisor i'm gonna be the super
okay that's not nope
clear that what what am i doing what
what what what's happening
what what
oh paramedic
okay hop in ah oh we gotta
we gotta work in one oh my god
oh so loud good god okay can we get some
emergencies
[Music]
hello
guys i'm really struggling i'm uh
guys i'm oh man i'm really struggling
i'm at a bit of a loss because i feel
like there's
an ocean of game underneath this surface
and i'm struggling to get through it's
thick ice that's preventing me from
going into the ocean i don't know why i
want to go into the ocean this is a bad
analogy because in no circumstance would
i ever want to go in the ocean
especially if it was covered in ice
that'd be awful i would not want
anything to do with that
there's a sand pit of
content and game underneath it and i
need to dig
in there get through all the cat turds
cause it's a public sandbox
where am i going all right new unit
fire department confirm
engine driver
we're here f1
oh what
fire fire okay fire we gotta fire open
that door
hello hello
okay
okay okay all the way out of the way all
the way all the way all the way out of
the way
[Music]
yeah it's not as exciting when there's
no cars to yell at it and crash into but
whatever okay this is it here we go i
see the fire
this is what my training is led up to
this is what i've been training for all
my life this is what i've really been
going for
where's the fire hydrant i'm going for
it right here
okay out of vehicle
okay i need
grab return quick i don't need the quick
attack line i need
the supply unit hose
supply line front suction what
one
no oh my god
oh
[Music]
god
oh my god i'm going into the fire
i'm going in the fire i'm going in the
fire
i'm going in fire and i will
have i will have a drink
i cannot i will die so uh thank you
everybody so much for watching this has
been emerge
nyc uh i'm sure there is game underneath
here i'm sure there is
and uh someday i will find it and also
now we're running like a turd
this fire effect is really intense i
don't want to say that this game is bad
because apparently for some people it
works really well
and you know maybe someday you know
actually i'm just gonna
maybe someday i will become smart enough
my brain will expand enough the wrinkles
will
take form and i will be able to
understand this game and all of its
intricacies
for now i am not smart enough so i
cannot
but thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to play this link
is in the description i wish you luck
you are going to need it
thank you for watching and as always i
will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
you